hey what's up guys my name is a Chan and
welcome back to my safe boss class
series today we're talking all about the
arrow operator in C++ we're going to
talk about what the arrow operator
actually does for both struct and class
pointers as well as implement our own
arrow operator to see how it works so
over here my source code of our basic
entity class type now if I create this
object normally as I probably would like
this in full print I have no issues but
if this entity object was actually a
pointer so either it's it was allocated
on the heap or maybe I just had a
pointer to it for some reason like this
in order to call that print function I
can't actually just use pointer dot
print like that because this is just a
pointer it's basically just a numerical
value I can't just called dot print on
it what I have to actually do is
dereference that pointer and that can be
done like so I can just say entity
reference entity for example and then
use the asterisk in front of the point
like this to dereference it and then
just substitute this with entity and my
card works now to avoid this extra line
what I could also do is use my pointer
but surrounded with parentheses and
dereference it like so now I can't just
write code like this because of operator
precedence it'll actually try and go to
the object or print and then dereference
the result of print that's obviously not
going to work so you have you have to
actually do the dereferencing first and
then call dot print now this this is
okay and it works fine but it looks a
little bit clunky so what we can do
instead is just use the arrow operator
instead of dereferencing the pointer and
then calling dot print we can substitute
all of that with just an arrow to print
like this and what this actually does is
dereference that entity pointer into it
just an all entity type and then calls
print so that's pretty much all there is
to it it's just a shortcut for having it
for us having to manually dereference
events around everything with
parentheses and then call our function
or our variable as well instead of doing
all that we can just use an arrow worst
variable as well if I had some variables
over here I'll just make public int X
for example I could also just you know
access X through the arrow like this and
then set it equal to whatever I wanted
to like so okay cool so that's pretty
much the default use case for the arrow
operator that's probably how you're
using it 90% of the time however as an
operator in C++ it is actually possible
to overload it and
use it in your own custom classes and
I'll show you an example of why you
might want to do that and how you can do
that over here so suppose that I was
writing some kind of smart pointer class
like subscribe to point up to keep it
simple I'm just going to have it have an
entity pointer when I construct this
script pointer
I'm going to take in an entity as a
parameter here and then assign it to my
object in the destructor I'm going to
call delete entity or delete M ulchhhh
and so now I've got a basically scope to
point a class that will automatically
delete my entity when it goes out of
scope so I can use it like source code
pointer entity equals new entity and
that looks pretty good now I want to
actually be able to call this print
function or access this X variable so
how do I do that well right now I can't
really like I can use dots but then like
I could make either this public or maybe
I could just have something that returns
an entity pointer like yet object like
this maybe that will return my object
that just looks way too messy I want to
be able to use it like a heap-allocated
entity right I want to be able to use it
as if I'd written code like this which
would mean that I could just write well
that and it would work fine I want to be
able to just substitute this and have it
kind of be used the same way well that's
where you can overload the arrow
operator make it do that for you instead
of get object I can write entity pointer
operator hour with no parameters like
this and then just return em all and you
can see suddenly this compiles and will
run just fine
if I hit f5 there you go you can see
that it's calling my function and
printing hello now in the case of this
being Const you could also provide a
constellation of this operator so I'll
copy and paste this have a return a
Constanta T and Mark the operators Const
like this and that will now return a
Const version of this and of course I've
marked this function as constic it
wasn't constituency I'm not able to call
that function so the function has to be
marked as Const over here as well and
everything basically works as if this
was just a Const pointer like that no
difference but now of course since it is
a scoped pointer I voted the deletion of
this actual object pretty cool stuff so
that's how you can overload the arrow
operator to function in your own classes
it's very powerful it's very useful
because you can see that you can start
to kind of define your
constructs and urine types in the
language and automate things and it
looks like normal code which is exactly
what we want a lot of people will argue
that that's a bit confusing because yeah
it might look like normal code but it's
not however I think that if you use it
properly and if you're sensible about it
then this this is actually really useful
and can help keep your code really clean
so fun I'm going to show you one more
way how we can actually use the arrow
operator to get the offset of a certain
member variable in memory so this is
kind of like a little bonus segment I
guess of this episode but it has to do
with the arrow operator soil I'll put it
in let's just say that we have a struct
here maybe called vector 3 and we
basically just have a 3 in front of back
to float X Y Z like this now suppose
that I actually wanted to find out what
the offset of this Y variable was in
memory so we know that this struct is
structured out of floats of course so
it's got float X Y and said each float
is 4 bytes so the offset of X is going
to be 0 it's the first thing in the
struct Y is going to be 4 because it's 4
bytes into the struct and then finally
set is going to be 8 bytes but what
happens if I suddenly move this around
then well the class is gonna work the
same way but they're going it's going to
have a different layout in memory so
maybe I want to write something for
myself that actually tells me the offset
of each of these members and I can do
something like that using the arrow
operator so what I want to do is kind of
access these variables but instead of
from a valid memory address just from 0
so this is kind of hard to explain but
if I'll but I'll show you what I mean
I'm literally going to write 0 and then
cost this into a vector 3 pointer like
so and then use the arrow to access X
and this is going to give me this is
going to try and give me some kind of
piece of invalid memory but what I'm
going to do is actually take the memory
address of that X so now what I'm doing
is basically getting the offset of that
X because I'm starting at 0 this could
also be written as null pointed by the
way and if I finally take that and just
cost it to a regular integer and write
offset over here I'll print that
and I'll hit up five you can see it
gives me zero so what I'll do next is
I'll change this to be Y and check out
what that looks like for that seems
right and then I'll change it to Zed and
of course the value should be eight and
you can see that it is so what we've
done here is we've used the arrow
operator to basically get the offset of
a certain value in memory
pretty cool stuff and this is actually
very useful for when you're serializing
data into like a stream of bytes and you
want to figure out offsets of certain
things and we'll kind of get into this
kind of exciting code when we start
doing the graphics programming series
and the game engine series and all that
because we'll be kind of dealing with
streams of bytes all the time anyway I
hope you guys enjoyed this episode if
you did and you hit the like button let
me know that you enjoyed it leave any
comments or feedback you might have in
the comment section below and if you
really enjoyed this series in this video
then you can support me on patreon by
going to patreon icon for search the
Cherno you'll get videos early you'll be
able to be in a private discord channel
where we talk about what goes into these
videos and all that fun stuff and of
course they're helping to support the
series and making sure that we make more
of these episodes I will see you guys in
the next one
good bye
[Music]
[Music]